Speaker 1: We have a voicemail number.
That number is two one nine two.
David P. Here is a delightful caller, thrilled
that she got vaccinated.
She's telling random strangers, listen to
the joy in her voice.
I love
Speaker 3: that.
This is Laura from Washington.
Yes.
And I was just watching the YouTube video
about the guy who calls have been threatening
you because you came back and you did.
Anyhow, I just want to tell you, because I
want to tell everybody, total strangers on
the street and then tell me I've got both
my devices, I I'm so happy.
So just my husband.
So is my son weird to be vaccinated?
Has.
And we are happy
Speaker 1: I am with you, Laura.
I am truly with you.
I wish more people would do the exact same
thing because we know the path out of the
pandemic.
We see the data.
We see what's happening in highly vaccinated
countries.
We see what's happening in the US, particularly
in the most highly vaccinated states.
There's no mystery here, folks.
There's really no mystery.
All right.
So let's let's do it.
On today's bonus show, we will talk about
the political aspect of Rudy Giuliani's son
running for governor of New York, particularly
when Rudy himself is potentially in a very
bad investigative situation with the walls
closing in around him.
What is that going to look like?
Number two, Bank of America will raise its
minimum wage to twenty five dollars per hour.
By twenty twenty five.
Wow, wow.
Or is it we will talk about it and also Texas
moving very quickly, no masks are required
at just about every Texas state facility anymore.
Is this logical based on the numbers?
Is this risky?
If yes, for who?
All of those questions and hopefully some
answers on today's bonus show get instant
access to the bonus show two ways.
Become a member at join Pakman Dotcom or become
a patron at Patreon dotcom.
Com The David Pakman Show.
Both ways you get instant access to the bonus
show.
It is a good one
Unidentified: today and I hope to see that.